va la vie je me dis tu es mort
oui je voudrais simplement vous dire
parce que les gens l'ont compris et ceux
qui sont derrière leur poste aussi vous
aimez régaler les gens qui sont derrière
le poste de télévision qui tous vous
regarde tous les soirs et qui vous
aiment et ils ont eu envie de vous
régalez vous maintenant ce soir oui et
ces gens là il y en a quelques-uns qui
sont là ce soir il s'appelle gaëtan
loide emilie priscilla pauline lucie
alex elodie et salimata avec moi mais de
le renseigner les gens qui te déjà tout
simple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si ce n'est des armes vient d'annuler le
verbaliser poterie c'est pour ça qu'on
dit et amis le temps de décrire une
le dis aux roms il sourit
là bas la vie
le temps de te dire hélas
qui ont des bras pour la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non c'est faux on ne sait trop d'où les
soirs on aggrave le sourire qu'on chérit
m
il a pris le temps de décrire une audi
omis le sourire barre à l'appui le temps
que teddy d'ennahda qui ont les bras
pour la vie la vie je te dis
tél
va qui entraînera pour la
mama
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
je connais tous j'ai vraiment des capots
merci merci d'avancé
merci aux chroniqueurs merci à vous
d'être aussi de vous souhaite de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année un joyeux noël je
vous aime voir et n'oubliez pas la télé
c'est qu'au delà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]